cold-open for you today because recently
I had to reinstall my operating system
when when I did that it secretly
switched audio inputs on me so I
recorded this entire episode with a
terrible microphone accidentally John's
gonna sound lovely and I will sound
terrible but I just wanted to let you
know that that was gonna happen and I'll
be sure to attend some audio production
workshops at pod con so what happens
less which by the way is in the middle
of its crowdfunding campaign see the
link e I admit a transition there with
so many cool people will be at pod con
Hannah Hart Cathy and Tobin of Nancy
Demi and me Alice punch up the jams Erin
manky of lure the McElroy brothers oh no
Ross and Carrie hello from the magic
cavern the bright sessions in so many
more so check it out pod con-com and now
get ready for some terrible audio hello
and welcome to dear Hank and John doors
I prefer to think of it Dear John and
Hank it's a comedy podcast where two
brothers answer your questions give me
devious advice and bring you all the
week's news from Mars and AFC Wimbledon
John what is the elephant in the room
alright Hank are you ready on three one
two three the elephant in the room oh
really right I think that sewed last
week John we we simultaneously elephant
it for the first rhyme and I feel like
maybe we should just end the elephant in
the room there and that the elephant of
the room is the elephant in the room
means that needs to be done with Hank
that is exactly what I was gonna propose
what a wonderful moment of mine mild
mind-melding between brothers i I agree
with you the elephant in the room it has
been beautiful and it's been wonderful
and it's been a great opening bit and it
has also ended yeah and I mean I think
that you like with this level of
adjustment is really what our audience
is here for they don't want the same
podcast every week John they want to
know that the opening bits gonna be
different and that from now on we're
gonna be doing reviews of chapstick and
just various kinds of lip balms
I like the chapstick review idea I don't
love it what I would say
is that we have our listeners email in
suggestions for opening bits at Hank and
John at gmail.com and we will use one of
them as the new opening bit unless none
of them are good in which case we will
use the chapstick idea we can or we
could have a different one I just had
chapstick here in front of me that's all
that happened I do want to put some on
my lips now though cuz it's always a
little bit dry here in Montana oh yeah
good John you wanna do some questions my
listeners know I want to turn this into
an ASMR podcast where you do nothing but
put chapstick on your woops yes I want
to answer questions from our listeners
alright first comes from Tim and Tim
asks dear Hank and John I know that Hank
has mentioned that his book an
absolutely remarkable thing comes out on
Tuesday September 25th and it's
available for pre-order now I know that
he has mentioned that not all pre-orders
will be signed however I couldn't anks
publisher just copy a page of Hanks
signature equal to the amount of all the
books that are pre-ordered and then
pre-orders will be signed I mean it's
just one extra piece of paper that needs
to be copied and bound in the beginning
of the book is this tall thing no 10
years of the essence Tim Oh Tim is of
the essence is a pretty good name
specific sign off if I were named Tim
every time I met people I would be like
hey my name's Tim is of the essence no
no please don't give that advice to Tim
I feel very bad that seems like the kind
of thing that like that like high school
John would totally have done and it was
not a good idea it's so true high school
John wearing his FAO Schwarz beanie with
little propeller on top would have
absolutely introduced himself as Tim as
of the essence despite not being named
Tim I used to think that being was so
cool John I used to think you were the
coolest person that you were confident
enough to wear that dumb fao schwarz
beanie and I want everyone to know that
that's not a thing we made up for that
was not like a bit that's actually a
thing that John did I wore it all the
time in high school I mean it was so
dirty pictures of there's pictures of me
wearing it in the flippin yearbook
anyway Tim we need to move past my
beanie immediately before
becomes like a recurring bit we've done
it with panic we've got to move on Tim
the reason that Hanks publisher can't
put digitally rendered copies of his
signature in every copy of an absolutely
remarkable thing is that that is not a
signature for something to be a
signature the human hand has to have
made it or the human foot yeah well I
did sign three or four with the foot but
it turned out that was pretty
inefficient the it makes me think that
like it's does Tim think that like I
didn't actually sign the books just
didn't think that this is just like a
like a picture of my signature it's a
lot of time signing books for people to
think that I spent a lot of time
thinking about this because I've signed
my name around four hundred fifty
thousand times in the last seven years
and that's given me ample time to think
about signing the thing that I've come
around to when thinking about signing is
that I'm trying to physicalize a very
weird thing I'm trying to like give it
form and structure and explain it to my
brain because brains are bad at big
numbers and I'm trying to tell my brain
a lot of people have put their trust in
you with this book and this is how
you're going to acknowledge it and
recognize it and kind of come to terms
with what it is and so I think that for
a signature to work at least for me it
still has to be a real signature made
with a marker preferably a sharpie etc
Jeffery wants to call in with the
sponsorship that would totally be
acceptable I don't want to get too I
don't want to get too sidetracked here
but Sharpie just launched a huge ad
campaign with Aaron judge who's on the
New York Yankees and at least from like
watching the commercials on Twitter does
not seem to be a particularly passionate
Sharpie user whereas you've got me
waiting in the wings somebody who's used
thousands of sharpies over the last ten
years somebody who has incredibly strong
feelings about sharpies and why they are
far and away the greatest permanent
marker in the history of our entire
civilization and we
Aaron judge talking about like how
sharpies can send positive messages come
on well he has had 82 homeruns I don't
know if he did any of those with
sharpies but that's more than you and
he's only 6 years old John six six foot
seven handsome man there's there's there
things that he has that you don't have
let's just all admit it oh oh yeah no he
is uh he is a pleasure to look at what
was the question
not really sure but I signed all of the
things that I only had somewhat enough
time to sign 40,000 and thank you so
much people who have purchased my book
pre-ordered it there will be signed
copies available at bookstores and at
places that sell books that aren't
bookstores but they have sold out on
Amazon but you can still get them Barnes
and noble.com if you want to check that
out Johnny you want to hit us with
another question yeah I kind of want to
wax poetic on how much I like your book
but we it's fun
would would just move on to the next
question I do really love your book
though and I'm so excited for everybody
to read it this question comes from
Ashlyn who writes Dear John and Hank I'm
16 years old and I am home alone for the
next few days while my mother is on a
camping trip it's night time now and I
am extremely fearful of home invasions
at the best of times let alone when I am
alone how do I survive these next few
days on my own any and all dubious
advices welcome and appreciated don't
harsh on my yums Ashley I got to admit I
don't have a lot of anxiety about this
kind of thing even though of course like
bad things do occur statistically they
occur less often than we might think but
that doesn't mean that they don't happen
is it possible that you can't can't you
can go home alone on this and just put
like bacon grease all over the doorknob
so that they just can't like you could
if they could pick the lock they could
but they can't even twist the knob or or
or hear me out
get a dachshund because as far as I can
tell it's scarier than a German Shepherd
like these little things that are full
of little mouth razors and I don't like
can you get a dachshund real fast like a
temporary loan dachshund go I'm sure
there are lots of people with dachshunds
out there who would be more than happy
to loan their dachshund to Ashman for a
week when I was a kid possibly
permanently just like this is enough
there's enough
and in my life it turns out I thought
that this was cute but it turns out it's
a dachshund
well dachshunds are very cute they're
great dogs don't get me wrong but when I
was a kid I had a dachshund and I also
had an experience similar to this Ashwin
because my parents and Hank went to
England for like a week when I was a
senior in high school and they left me
behind there's no need to get into the
details of why this happened but I ended
up spending a week at home by myself in
a very similar situation I am also a
fairly anxious person so I can totally
relate to what you're going through
Ashlyn and I did find it very helpful to
have our dog red/green there although I
mean red/green who was a beautiful
dachshund was also a very difficult dog
and my primary memory of that week is
that every morning I was working the
graveyard shift at Steak and Shake and
every morning I would come home go to
sleep red/green would jump up on my bed
scratch up my face to wake me up and
then you look at me we'd make eye
contact
I'd be like good morning red how are you
and the name would jump down onto the
carpet and then still staring at me he
would pee yeah he did have a defiant pee
Street he really liked you to know that
he was doing it it was extremely
important for him to be making eye
contact with you when he peed on the
carpet
Scottie I think we helped ya know
anything John we've solved another
problem if you could have one extra eye
on your body where would you decide to
put it obviously it would be nice to see
things behind you but it may come with
lots of added sensitivity that would get
in the way of an active and productive
lifestyle would it be better just to put
it on the forehead and continue living a
regular lifestyle I'll be it with a
strangely placed eyepatch why would you
cover it up Scotty doesn't know but
wants to wait Scotty does this
hypothetical third eye not blink like am
I not allowed to close it well that's
the thing can you just have it closed
most of the time and then only open it
sometimes does that be good but I I
assume I assume that it's a fully
functioning iock and blanket can close
it can squint it has tear ducts ah this
okay in that case I don't even think
there's a competition there's only one
possible answer I assume you agree with
me okay I have my answer my answer is
the inside of the wrist Oh interesting I
was thinking the palm of my left hand
well but then you're gonna like cover it
up with your fingers sometimes yeah yeah
III didn't think like that it'd be
cooler a little bit to have an eye on
the the palm of the hand like that's a
very like a good visual but I think that
it's definitely a more yeah but then
every time you shake hands with somebody
your eyes gonna get like up real close
to their skin flesh
yeah probably gonna get a sty definitely
gonna get a sty if it's on the hands
it's just always very dirty ya know the
ins the inside of the wrist is the
obvious place and that way you can
swivel so you can look forward you can
look backward you can also do the sort
of periscope thing where you just reach
your arm around a doorway and then yeah
quick yeah so Hank last night I actually
just for fun the great thing about kids
and as your son gets older you'll learn
this the great thing about kids is that
they're pretty suggestible and they're
not totally sure of reality right
because everything so new and there's a
lot of weird things that are true so who
knows so I was reading these questions
last night going through them and I said
to Alice hey Alice I can see you with my
foot I she was kind of standing in the
doorway and I couldn't really see her
but I could see her reflection and she
said no you can't you don't have a foot
I and I was like no yeah I can you're
wearing your jean shorts and your
t-shirt that says let's be mermaids and
Alice was like you can see your third
eye and I was like yeah with my good eye
the eye on my foot oh good and then they
spent a solid hour trying to like test
the hypothesis that Dad had a foot I
good I like it I just in general I like
I like you know how harmless child
pranks so very good very good on you but
but maybe there would be something to it
being a foot I and people maybe maybe
won't see it as easily if it's down
there and he just sort of like thumb
like you just like toe your sock off and
then it's like looking around yeah I
don't know
I also get to call it a foot I so that's
good I mean I probably would honestly
probably stick it in the back of my head
so they'd be covered with my hair most
the time some people wouldn't have to
know about it and the negatives lift up
the hair if I wanted to see behind me
that'd be cool all I know for sure is
that I want a t-shirt that says let's be
mermaids it doesn't seem fair that Alice
gets to have that t-shirt and I don't um
you know John you're the kind of guy who
can make something like that happen if
you really want to there's like the
Internet is designed for people like
that I feel like you're the kind of guy
who can make something like that happen
and I'm the kind of guy who's going to
end up having to pay for half the
manufacturing costs or you're the guy is
gonna get a really nice birthday present
from your brother oh man that would be
awesome I mean if that's what you're
getting me for my birthday I'll be
absolutely thrilled all right I think I
feel like we're a little bit off the
rails here green alright well hit me
with another question then boy
okay Hank this next question comes from
Kim who writes Dear John and Hank I have
a problem I stayed overnight at a
friend's place last night and she's gone
to work today leaving me alone in her
apartment for a few hours here's the
problem I cleaned her bathroom I won't
see her again before I leave and my
worry is that this may come off as rude
or like I'm judging her at the time I
thought I was being nice but this is a
recurring issue in my life as I hope I
could have been accused of
passive-aggressive cleaning what should
I do
Kim oh gosh what a good problem to have
I guess you got to make that bathroom
dirty again I'm just gonna go like like
kind of Barris leave them around me miss
around I don't know yeah just put some
toothpaste on some stuff and rub it in I
guess I I need to get some friends who
passive-aggressively clean right yeah no
I like it came in all honesty I know
that you've probably fixed this problem
by now but I think that you did it good
I think that you helped and that no one
will see that as anything but beat you
being nice and saying and and you could
if you wanted to be like thanks for
letting me stay at your place to say
thanks I cleaned up it your bathroom not
because it was gross but because I like
you I think that's great great advice
Hank and hopefully the kind of advice
that's going to make Kim like us enough
to you know stop by for a cocktail
sometime
gives me the bathroom for a while huh
[Laughter]
how many times do you think I'd have to
have Kim over on consecutive Wednesdays
before she noticed that there was an
ulterior motive yeah where it's just
like man he invites us over every
Wednesday afternoon it's crazy I'm gonna
clean the bathroom for an hour after we
hang out and then I head home I have a
friend who invariably if you invite
invite him over and you have food he
will do all the dishes
he does it every single time to that it
is just like it's to the point where I
like I'm like you're too good you're too
good of a person I don't understand what
it's like to be you I could I would
never and now I like I've started to
like try and be this like in modeling of
my friend Brian to be the kind of person
who like while everybody else is off
doing something like sneaky look in the
kitchen
start to do some dishes and they come in
here are you doing the dishes I just
thought it'd be a nice help I thought
and I never would I have that idea on my
own but Brian every time he's doing the
dishes so great Eilis I want to hug him
right now I will say this I usually do
the dishes at parties that I attend and
you know is a slightly selfless act but
it is mostly selfish mostly at that
point in the party there's been so much
like talking among humans and social
contact and everything that what I
really want is I want to be alone for 45
minutes and there is no place more alone
at a party than the dishwashing station
you just pop out your Bluetooth
headphones and you know like I literally
will put on a podcast and do the dishes
very happily for 45 minutes and feel
restored and able to return to the party
I got another question John it's an
important one it's one that I've been
wondering about for a long time myself
and I did research to answer it so we'll
see what you think and then you'll find
out what I know it's for Matt who
dear Hank and John big fan of the pod my
question to you is simple why do we call
underwear a pair of underwear last I
recalled my undergarments were a single
unit not a pair of units keeping things
brief Matt yes yeah that's great well
done very good question so here's what I
know Hank you know the phrase everybody
puts their pants on one leg at a time or
you'll hear someone say like well Elon
Musk puts his pants on one leg at a time
just like the rest of us mm-hmm
I've never understood that phrase
because I have always put my pants on
both legs at the same time to save time
do you just jump and like do this like
is it like a dangerous acrobatic
maneuver no I mean it's gonna surprise
you to learn that it's not a
particularly athletic maneuver unlike
Sharpie spokesman Aaron judge I'm not a
professional athlete no I lie down on on
on my bed on my back and I pull my pants
on both legs at the same time as as far
back as I can remember and so whenever
anybody's like uh everybody puts their
pants on one leg at a time I always
think to myself I don't not me man my
guess is that people used to put their
pant legs on one at a time because they
were actually separate pant legs and
that that is why they are called a pair
of pants or a pair of underwear is that
it used to actually be a pair that is
correct
John you got it correct and there's all
kinds of well kinds of these like
breeches shorts panties knickers
trousers all plural because once upon a
time we would put each pant like there
would be was basically like a skirt for
each leg kind of and then you'd tie them
up like chaps like cowboy chaps and you
would tie them up at the top whereas a
shirt would be like a single unit of
cloth and pants would be two different
separate units of cloth weird to me it
feels like one of those things where
where our words remember things that we
have forgotten and I think that's so
cool when that happens that's a lovely
way of saying it Hank and a great
reminder that even after we're
on little parts of us survived like
pants like I don't know why I had to
take your lovely sentiment and then turn
it into a really bad metaphor but I mean
I guess that sort of my stock in trade
I'm happy I'm happy with it I think it
all turned out well okay all right Nick
we got another question this one's from
Lou who writes Dear John and Hank my
coworker just emailed me a question even
though we sit five feet away from each
other there are no walls or dividers
between us as in we're not in cubicles
or separate offices or whatever totally
a shared space do I answer the question
by responding to the email or simply by
answering out loud in my regular voice
because I don't need to shout skip to my
Lou I think there is a how I would do
this and I how office etiquette should
be answer to this question which what
should I give Joe how would you do this
Hank I would say it's it's 6:30 the
meeting is at 6:30 is how I would do it
Oh see I would I would be even more
passive aggressive than that I would be
like I think if you look in your
calendar you'll see when the meeting is
why don't you show me there Sean you
should have to do some kind of
challenging physical activity before
you're allowed to write an email you
should have to do like 25 push-ups and
then at the end of 25 push-ups you can
write one email and then the next time
you want to write an email you can be
like do I want to do 25 more push-ups or
do I want to talk to the person who's 5
feet away from me or like I mean this is
like legitimate like workplace
frustrations I have like I need you to
be thinking how can I make this the last
email in this thread like what is there
a probability that I can answer all of
the questions with this one email and if
you got to do 25 push-ups before you
send another one you're gonna
real hard about making this one perfect
and they like solving all the problems
as fast as possible I'm not trying to
acquire penpals I'm trying to get my
inbox to zero yeah I mean like what
blue-blue my situation here is like if
there's something like this is person
meet-up paper trail I can they trying to
like make sure that they that they can
prove that they did this that is what I
assume they have to have a paper trail
so that they can show their supervisor
oh no look I did email Lou about this at
3:13 p.m. on Tuesday or whatever but how
horrifying is that to have that much of
your life exist only for the purpose of
bureaucracy that is that is frustrating
in those situations but is it also like
in the in sort of office etiquette it
may be that like we're just trying to
keep the noise level down like we're
like we're not trying to distract we're
in an open office floor plan this is not
the best way for like the best system
for productivity and so we're trying to
keep we're trying to keep the the
talking to a minimum I don't want to
have a conversation right now I just
need to know when when we're meeting
with our new client chapstick it's at
6:30 p.m. and also I think it's actually
Sharpie reminds me that the sponsor of
this podcast is of course the sharpie
stick it's a new collaboration between
chapstick and Sharpie where you could
just it's like a really fine point
plastic and that you can really draw it
on there perfectly what Hank what it's a
sharpie on one end and chapstick on the
other just made the most important
innovation in the actual history of
chapstick Hank
after so many consecutive terrible ideas
you've had away great idea this idea is
as good as Dorito tacos this is an idea
that is going to reshape the history of
humanity I don't know if we need to call
chapstick first or Sharpie first are
they owned by the same company Hank I
cannot believe that you just had that
idea holy cow all right well I'm glad
you like it
I don't but
I believe you I believe in you John I
believe in your passion for my bad idea
that wasn't even actually my idea
chapstick is owned by pyth Iser I am her
of course you know they're there in the
they make viagra and chapstick I think
those are their two big products and
Sharpie is owned by it's owned by Newell
brands which is a bunch of a bunch of
things but I think Rubbermaid is their
biggest brand okay
Newell brands they got any chapstick do
they own like blistex or something I'm a
I am about to change the history of
Newell brands and take it from a
struggling producer of pens and sharpies
to the largest oh they own actually that
they are a very large company they seem
very doing fine I'm not sure that they
necessarily need us oh they don't know
they enough they own a fishing pole
company John they could make Sharpie
fishing poles though I can't they own a
candle company why don't they make
Sharpie candles you know yeah what it
lights what it lights while you're right
Wow John right we were talking about the
sponsors today's podcast is also brought
to you by Aaron judge Aaron judge I
think he plays for the Yankees I'm
pretty sure that's correct and also the
podcast is brought to you by John's 1992
fao schwarz beanie acquired and worn a
lot hmm boy as much as I wish it had
been 1992 I regret to inform you that it
was 1994 when I was 16 and lastly
today's podcast is brought to you by
plural pants plural pants because there
used to be two of them and finally we
have our actual sponsor John we've got a
real sponsor or sponsor today is
hellofresh
it's a meal kit delivery service that
shops and plans and delivers
step-by-step recipes and pre-measured
ingredients so that you can cook eat and
enjoy
John wait are you up with the hellofresh
these days oh yeah we just had a hell of
a fresh meal like last night how good
for you what was it last night we had
Hawaiian chicken poke a bowls good job
it was so good and also they give you
all the nutrition information so I was
able to make sure that it was
well inside the nutritional needs that I
have at the moment because I'm trying to
just shake just a little bit just a
little bit Kevin and I recently we do
the vegetarian the hello freshers for
the most part that we would Cajun will
switch over to the meat just for an
exciting week I'm got they had these
like this pita pocket recipe where it's
like a PITA and then there's sweet
potatoes and avocado and then pine nuts
in it it's so good if you had that last
week and I'm a big big fan hello fresh
has three different plans you can choose
from you got classic veggie and family
and each bock is made up of fresh
responsibly obtained ingredients from
carefully selected farms and high rated
trusted sources
it's like fuss-free easy to figure out
how to make food cleanup is actually
really really quick generally which is
good because that's mostly what I'm
responsible for and for $30 off your
first week of hellofresh you can go to
hellofresh comm and enter Dear John or
dear Hank in the offer code they both
work but Dear John is better dear Hank
is it's so good it's gonna get you the
exact same same discount but like I
don't know I've always found that Hank
is just easier to type John is easier to
type you can do it all with one hand
it's your--it's it's all right-handed
it's good - it's good to mix it up the
hands though so that you get when your
hand gets a little chance to recover in
the middle of the word once again that's
hellofresh comm enter the offer code
Dear John or dear Hank this next
question this is real one John you ready
for a real one yeah let's get let's get
real hey asks dear Hank and John my name
is Hayley and I'm very connected to my
Norwegian heritage most folks were on
front are all good nor sk's which is
signified by my last name I've always
loved my family and heritage and my name
however on November 3rd I'm getting
married and have agreed to change my
name to green Kaylee you're gonna be a
green this is exciting oh oh never mind
no offense but I don't really like this
name it's very common yeah fair enough
it's very she says it's very common
which I don't know if I agree with that
and I already have a very common first
name my fiance has an Irish heritage but
has no connection to it I've had my name
my whole life and it's part of who I am
I have a sick
sure and everything I don't really want
to change my name but I've agreed to do
it I will change it but I want to do it
joyfully this feels like a loss the two
of you have had your name for a while
now and I was wondering if you have some
advice on how to love being a green best
regards the future
Hayley green Hayley I don't know that
you're gonna like my advice but it's
pretty clear from your email that you
don't really want to change your name
and I know that's a little bit of a leap
for me to make but the part of the email
that I'm thinking about is the part
where you say and I'm quoting directly
here I don't really want to change my
name I don't think you should change
your name yeah I think that you should
continue to be Hayley with the Norwegian
last name that makes you feel connected
to your heritage and I don't think
that's going to have a negative impact
on your marriage as you say I've had my
name my whole life and it's part of who
I am I know you may have agreed to
change it but now's the time it gets
much harder after you change it to
change it back so I think you have a
series of conversations with the person
you're marrying and as part of that say
I like my name it connects me to my
heritage and I don't really want to
change it and if they really really want
you to change it that's a little bit of
a red flag for me I feel the same and
when you say that this is something
you've agreed to I think it's really
important when you're especially going
to have like a very long term
relationship that you recognize that
sometimes you agree to things that you
don't realize how much you were asking
of yourself and you need to change that
expectations and you need to you know
like correct that and that's something
that you know it's not like you make one
decision in that decision stands forever
like that these things have to be
conversations and they have to be part
of you know what you know and also like
part of the forgiveness of a
relationship that said Hank and I
completely agree with you what are some
of the awesome things about having the
last name green it's it's it's green
like the color is that you don't have to
explain to people how to spell it I
occasionally will say
Green like the color and then someone
will say back to me with an e on the end
and I say no no just GRE but it is
usually pretty easy to get people to
spell your last name which is a big
upside there's no yeah another big
advantage of it Haley is that sometimes
you'll meet someone and you'll tell them
your name and they'll say your last name
is a color and you'll say yes and then
they won't really have a follow-up so
that's always a fun conversation though
sometimes is a meet you about that like
oh I also have my last thing is also a
color that's we have that in common or
they'll be like my last name is also a
noun and I'll be like is it Forrester
and they're like yeah the Subaru
Forester well a forester is a noun it's
it's a person a forester is a person
does forestry know yes a forester is a
car made by subaru well what would it be
besides a noun you're right it's just
the Subaru you're right oh actually a
forester is a person who practices
forestry you're right I was right the
whole time and that is exactly what the
Wikipedia page hey you want to you want
me to read you a list of notable
foresters look at this photo of
foresters or should we save that for
this weekend ryan's oh man this is a
pretty long list of notable foresters
John I mean I will say this I've heard
of exactly one of these purportedly
notable foresters I've heard of two of
them who Geoffrey Chaucer and uh John
Muir John Muir of course yeah I guess I
guess I'm also Aldo Leopold
they're so good notable foresters didn't
Aldo Leopold write a sand County Almanac
it's possible did you know that there
was a notable Forester named Karl von
Carla wits so Hayley I mean at least
it's not that bad right I mean at least
not change your name to like hey leave
on her wits
on heylia whit's hahahaha
actually back up everything what you
guys need to do Haley is that thing you
know that thing now with a lot of young
couples where instead of one person
picking the other's last name they just
come up with a totally new last name I
think that's what it should be it should
be Vaughn Haley whit's well you changed
his name to Vaughn Haley wit so you
changed your name to Vaughn whatever his
name is Vaughn Greenwoods
okay well I think their name probably is
green green although we don't have
direct evidence of that John what do you
think is the farthest that Erin judge
could hit a baseball with a sharpie I'm
trying to get over my feelings about
Erin judge being the new spokesperson
for Sharpie but I mean the guy really
did take my dream job right out from
under me I mean you've been trying to
cultivate that relationship for years
and what what did he do nothing you know
what you think that he like has been
talking up sharpie on social media for
the last five years no no no he's just
been hitting home run got a good agent
is all he did and hit home runs and was
handsome in six seven which which to be
fair is a major accomplishment
Haley you're gonna be just fine no
matter what Godspeed whether you're a
green or anything else we are excited
for you and for your future absolutely
John you want to hit me with some of
that AFC Wimbledon news Oh Hank it's
been a devastating week for AFC
Wimbledon Oh No I thought things we're
looking up devastating so sorry John
Meade's are left back at the age of just
26 one of the best players for AFC
Wimbledon over the last several years
and a wonderful person when he received
the man of the match award when Henry
and I went to a game together and he
spent so much time with Henry during the
the ceremony after the after the game
you know the players are often in the
bar area after the game but Meade's he
spent so much time with Henry and was so
kind to him and Henry still says that
John means is his favorite soccer player
but after signing a new contract with
AFC Wimbledon in June unfortunately John
Meade's has decided that he has to
retire from professional football at the
age of just 26 because of his persistent
ankle injuries so it's a really sad
thing because he's such a great guy and
such a wonderful player the kind of
professional that any any team would
would want to have but he's had these
ankle problems for a long time he's had
several surgeries and unfortunately he
just doesn't feel like he's able to go
on playing at a professional level so
John means sad retire just a few days
before the beginning of the League One
season
Wimbledon have signed a replacement a
guy named Ben purring t'en which is
pretty great name Neely have you
considered the last name purring Tim
he's 22 and he's on loan from Rotherham
United who were promoted up from the
third tier to the second tier this
season so good luck to Ben purring
tenacity vast ated four means e what a
great guy and what a great player and I
wish him all the best in the future
well John as you probably have heard the
news from Mars is big and it's big and
it's exciting and it's really big big
real babies it gets some well it could
get bigger we're still working on our
way to the biggest news John alright
Hank what's rise surprise humans landing
on the planet before 2028 that's the big
news waiting for just without anybody
without anybody knowing it's good it
happened it just happened was that super
focused on getting humans to Mars right
now
the big news is that there there is a
European Space Agency instrument that
has been doing a bunch of work on like
in taking readings from Mars basically
with with like ground-penetrating radar
so they like hits Mars with a like a
high-energy sound wave basically and
that bounces back to the craft and it
can measure like when different echoes
come back so of course the big one comes
back right when is the surface but then
some of that stuff goes down and then
when it hits changes in the kinds of
materials its passing through it bounced
like certain amounts bounces back and
based on how much bounces back you can
tell what those transitions are between
areas and it is very clear after a lot
of looking and a lot of remeasuring of
this area that there is a subsurface
lake that's way down like it's more than
a kilometer down under the surface so
it's not like it's easily accessible or
anything but a subsurface lake of liquid
water and the way that this water is
liquid because this is that that is it's
like at the pole it's very cold it's
cold all the way down it's not it
doesn't seem to be being heated by
geothermal energy sources or something
which would be the most exciting way
that this could be warm it seems to be
there or liquid it seems to be liquid
because it is really really briny so it
has a lot of perchlorate salts which
help the water not turn into ice because
it prevents the the crystals from
forming and there's also some thought
that it might be pretty slushy like a
lot of like mixed around with mud and
dirt and particles and stuff but it is
liquid water we're almost entirely sure
and though that percentage of
perchlorate salts that would make it
like the highest the high percentage
that would be necessary for it to stay
liquid would be the kind of amount of
perchlorate salts that would make it
pretty difficult for life to live there
perchlorates are toxic to us you'd
certainly don't want to consume any of
them but there are organisms on earth
that actually consume perchlorates but
this level of this level of perchlorate
like saturation would not be something
that would make those organisms happy so
we're not sure what it means
it probably is that it's very briny and
very like full of full of perchlorate
salts which is not great for life but
it's certainly better for life than no
liquid water at all and then I've
actually was able to talk a little bit
with some people who at the ESA and at
the Planetary Society about this like
how likely it is that it might be some
combination of geothermal heat and
perchlorates they can actually tell
pretty well that you know looking at the
surface temperatures there and and sort
of modeling how heat gets passed around
it seems like there's probably not a lot
of heat down there that's keeping it
liquid it's it's it's just the chemical
composition of the water so that's cool
that's good that's big it's weird but in
general like Mars turns about to be a
pretty wet place definitely was a very
wet place even on its surface billions
of years ago
so could be the kind of place where you
know life existed once and and has maybe
even held on in some places the question
being like if we could even figure out
what life looks like if it's that
different from us where it can survive
in that kind of environment but but wet
water allows for a lot of interesting
chemistry to happen and that is a very
cool thing to know is there on Mars so
we know the waters wet we know that it's
kept liquid probably not by being super
warm but instead because it's so briny
yeah and we know that it's brine eNOS is
probably not great for life correct
correct yes probably not but maybe not a
deal-breaker for life you know life
finds a way I mean the thing that I keep
coming back to and I this is something I
will follow with great interest for the
rest of my life but the thing I keep
coming back to is that even on earth
life isn't really a dichotomy this is
alive that is not alive it's much more
like a continuum this is more alive than
that and I wonder if when we go to Mars
or know more about Mars if that
continuum is going to become even
weirder and less certain and more
problematic because
then we'll have to decide well is this
life when it's so different from the
life that we know and experience here
and not only that we'll have to figure
out do we have to protect that life like
do do we have to stay off of that planet
because our life probably is gonna be
better at being life than that life and
and if we start changing changing the
surface chemistry of Mars changing the
atmospheric composition do we basically
say like well not only are we gonna like
extinct some species right now if this
is an entirely different lineage of life
are we going to extinct an entire new
kind of kind of like you know sort of
chemical sustainability for lack of a
different term right and then are humans
gonna have to make the difficult
decision not to go which humans are so
bad at right like humans are so bad at
resisting the urge to explore something
I just made an episode of the
Anthropocene reviewed about the caves at
Lausanne in part because humans have
done a pretty good job over the last 70
years of stopping going when it became
unsustainable for them to be there but I
feel like with something as big and
exciting and full of possibility as life
on another planet we're gonna have a
really hard time not going yeah I
absolutely agree with you I don't know
how to how to hold that back myself
because I certainly want to go I mean
not personally I I love I love it in my
chair oh yeah god no not personally but
I I I would like some other people to go
and report back to me on what it was
like we've got a project for awesome
message this week from Frederick Garzon
from Paris France who contributed to the
project for awesome Thank You Frederick
I apologize by the way if I'm
mispronouncing your name it's been a
number of years since my high school
French classes and as my high school
French teacher would be happy to point
out I was also a terrible student
a quick cuckoo to the French speaking
nerdfighters out there Hank and John are
City for everything you do with the
project for awesome crash course and
scishow you prove every day that the
Internet is a great place to bring
positive change to Society of God
Frederick I'm glad you believe that I
hope that I still can oh boy by the way
when will VidCon come
to France mmm great question and that's
more of a question for Hank than for me
I don't I have no plans currently to
bring VidCon to France but VidCon is
coming across the English Channel to
England and that's very close by yes
able to see you at VidCon VidCon UK if
not if not VidCon francais yes very good
John very good Hank what did we learn
today John we learned that Karl honkala
wits DeForest it we also learned that
signed books are or at least should be
actually signed and we learned that you
should do the dishes when you're at a
party because everybody will think
you're doing that everybody's such a
nice thing but in fact you're just
trying to not for a second and lastly we
learned that if you want to protect your
home always get a dachshund nope no one
will burgle that dachshund the trouble
is trouble yeah I mean that robber is
gonna get their ankles bitten off
no you won't have all your on your
eyeball ankle we'll just get that
dachshund tooth right in it you're gonna
lose your foot I for sure all right John
thank you for podcasting with me as
absolute pleasure if anybody has any
suggestions for opening bits or of
course questions you can send this to
Hank and John at gmail.com if you want
to put in the subject line opening bits
so we know that that's an opening bid
and not a question that will help us
when we're organizing things this
podcast is produced by rosianna halse
rojas and sheridan Gibson it's edited by
the great Nicholas Jenkins our head of
community and communications is Victoria
bon giorno the music that you're
listening to right now and also the
music at the beginning of the podcast
was written by gunnarolla you can follow
us on Twitter at Hank green or at John
Green we also have a patreon for dear
Hank and John at patreon.com slash dear
Hank and John where we are about to
record our patrons only terrible podcast
to this week in Ryan's thank you again
for listening and as they say in our
hometown don't forget to be awesome
[Music]